l'actualité très présente au festival de
cannes il n'y a pas que les paillettes
actualité internationale on l'a vu hier
avec le film beauce nappe de bernard
henri lévy sur la guerre en bosnie mais
aussi les faits divers avec le film de
claire denis
inspiré d'un fait divers horrible les
meurtres de vieilles dames de thierry
paulin reportage de nicolas vin clairet
n gicquel poulain le tueur l'arakan le
titre était plutôt accrocheur l'assassin
d'une vingtaine de vieille dame faisait
ce matin un passage express de la
rubrique faits divers aux pages culture
mais il faut paraît-il se méfier du
mélange des genres il faut aussi
racontent les maires prévenante se
méfier des regards et volver
ça fait mal quand il dégaine c'est quoi
on m'invite pour un film qu'est ce qu'on
s'en alla donc avec quel point je peux
tourner avec richard avait clair sur un
sujet sur qui n'a rien à voir avec tyr
et plein de fois j'ai pas sommeil
c'est l'histoire de destins croisés un
meurtrier ses proches et sa famille des
êtres qui ne savent plus se comprendre
béatrice dalle y joue le rôle de la
belle soeur de l'assassin le couple
semble avoir quelques petits flottements
c'est 3 attendu mais ne se serait jamais
prête chaque fois que j'essaie de te
parler du contre-plan que c'est pas ce
qu'on a fait on aurait dit qu'on
ailleurs c'est richard course et qui
incarne thierry colin dans ce film on
dira plutôt l'assassin pour ne pas se
fâcher avec béatrice donc l'assassin des
problèmes avec tout et tout le monde à
commencer par l'argent est lui-même ou
c'est l'argent
mais tu me dis ça tous les jours demain
d'accord demain bonne soirée quand même
et surtout soyez passage certains faits
divers fonds sont comme des loupes un
petit peu sur sur la vie convient le
malgré tout les films ils sont faits
avec la matière du monde la matière des
villes la latière des gens pour croire
vers denis a voulu bien au delà du fait
divers démonter les mécanismes de nos
souffrances infinies parfois très dures
dans un univers sulfureux